côte à côte les cinq rafale escorté par
deux avions russes fendent le ciel en
direction de l'inde après un voyage de
plusieurs heures ils ont atterri sur la
base militaire damballa dans l'état
indien du haryana ces cinq rafale sont
les premiers à être livrées sur les 36
commandé par l'inde à dassault montant
estimé du contrat 9,4 milliards de
dollars le ministre de la défense indien
a profité de l'occasion pour lancer un
avertissement à peine voilé à la chine
alors que les deux pays entretiennent
des relations tendues
je voudrais ajouter que si quelqu'un
doit s'inquiéter de ces nouvelles
capacités de l'armée de l'air indienne
où les critiques et ce devrait être ceux
qui veulent menacer notre intégrité
territoriale
le 15 juin dernier en incident sanglant
a éclaté entre militaires indiens et
chinois dans le ladakh une région
disputée entre les deux pays
une vingtaine de soldats indiens pelli
c'est lors de cette confrontation qui a
conduit à un renforcement de la présence
militaire indienne dans la zone après
quelques jours de tension la chine et
l'inde avaient cependant annoncé
poursuivre les discussions afin
d'apaiser la situation
du côté chinois nous ne voulons
assurément plus voire deux heures avec
les indiens c'est dans ce contexte de
discorde avec la chine mais aussi avec
le pakistan que l'inde renouvelle sa
flotte vieillissante d'avions de combat
mais ce contrat passé avec dassault a
déclenché les protestations de
l'opposition indienne
celle ci est notamment accusé le
gouvernement donne à rennes drame audi
d'avoir favorisé le conglomérat privé
ryan ce groupe comme partenaire de
dassault aux dépens de l'entreprise
publique h à elle la polémique n'a
pourtant pas remise en cause le contrat
avec l'avionneur français qui espère
profiter de ces dissensions pour vendre
davantage de rafale à new delhi et la
commande actuel doit être totalement
livrés d'ici fin 2021